right over here i have the graph of f of
x and what i want to think about in this
video is whether we could have sketched
this graph just by looking at the
definition of our function which is
defined as a rational as a rational
expression we have 2x plus 10 over 5x
minus 15.
so there's a couple of ways to do this
first you might just want to pick out
any numbers that are really easy to
calculate so for example what happens
when x is equal to zero so we could say
f of zero
f of zero is going to be equal to well
all the x terms are going to be zero so
you're going to be left with 10 over
negative 15 which is negative 10 15
which is negative two thirds so you
could plot that when x equals zero f of
x or y equals f of x is negative two
thirds and we see that point let me do
that in a darker color you see that
point right over there so we could have
plotted that point we could have also
said when does this function equal zero
well the function is equal to zero when
the only way to get the function equal
to zero is if you get this numerator
equal to zero so you could try to solve
two x plus ten is equal to zero well
that's going to happen when two x is
equal to negative 10 i just subtracted
10 from both sides and if i divide both
sides by 2 that's going to happen when x
is equal to negative 5. and you see that
you see this right over here when x is
equal to negative 5 the function
intersects the x-axis so that's just two
points but that still doesn't give us
enough to really form this interesting
shape over here and you could think
about what other functions have this
type of this type of shape so now what i
want to think about is the behavior of
the function at different points
so first i want to think about
when this function is undefined and what
type of behavior we might expect for
that function when it's undefined
so this function is going to be
undefined the only way i can think of to
make this undefined is if i make the
denominator equal to zero we don't know
what it means to divide by zero that is
undefined so this the function is going
to be undefined when 5x which is in blue
when 5x minus 15 is equal to 0 or adding
15 to both sides when 5x is equal to 15
or dividing both sides by 5 when x is
equal to 3
f
is
undefined
now there's a couple of ways for a
function to be undefined at a point you
could have something like this so let's
let me draw some axes right over here
so let's say that this is 3
you could have your function it could
look like this it could be defined it
might kind of approach something
but just not be defined right at 3 and
then just keep on going like that or the
other possibility is it might have a
vertical asymptote there and if it has a
vertical asymptote it's going to look
something like this it might it might be
approach it might just pop up
to infinity and then it might pop down
from infinity on this side or it might
go from negative infinity right over
here that's as that's what a vertical
asymptote would look like that as we
approach from the left the graph is
approaching a vertical
but never it never quite gets to x
equals three i guess one way you could
say it or the function is defined not
defined at x equals three and as you
approach from the right the same thing
the function just in this case drops
down it almost becomes vertical it's
approaching negative infinity as x
approaches 3 from the positive direction
so how would we know obviously when you
look at here when you look when we know
the graph ahead of time and if you say
okay this is this is x equals 10. so
let's see how many this is one two three
four
five so each of these are two so x
equals three is right over here when you
look at the graph if you had the graph
in front of you you would see oh look
this is indeed a vertical asymptote just
looking at the graph you see that you
have a vertical asymptote at x equals
three and let me write that down
vertical asymptote
vertical
asymptote
asymptote at x equals 3 at x equals 3
but how would you have known that how
would you have known that if you didn't
have the graph here if you just had this
we know it's not defined at 3 but how do
we know it's not a point discontinuity
and not a instead of a vertical
asymptote well there's a couple of ways
to do it one way is you could try values
near three and see what happens so for
example you could get your calculator
out and you could try
let's say 3.01
so if you say 2 times 3.01
plus 10 actually well that's the
numerator and then i'm going to divide
that the numerator by 5 times 3.01
minus 15.
it gets us a fairly large number it's
kind of exploding on us and if we've got
even closer so if we did
2
times 3.001
plus
let me plus 10
plus 10
divided by
5 times
3.001 so now i'm just
now i'm trying x is equal to
3.001
minus 15
minus 15. we see we get even a larger
number so as x gets closer and closer to
three f of x seems to be exploding it
seems to be approaching positive
infinity so that's one way to say okay
this looks like at least from this side
we are approaching we are approaching
positive infinity so we would have been
able to draw
we would have been able to draw
something like that and then you could
have tried values below you could have
tried values below so you could have
said
actually let me just let me just put the
last
entry here and let me just change the
3.001 to 2.999
2.999
and
whoops let me go over here
we have
2.999
and we get notice we're going really
negative now we're approaching negative
infinity so if you just tried that out
that would give you a pretty good
indication that the graph is looking
something like that right over here
which also seems to match connecting
these two points that we've already
thought about but now let's see what's
going on as x approaches really large
values or really negative really
positive values or really negative
values
it looks like there is a horizontal
asymptote here just looking at the graph
just looking at the graph it seems like
there's some value that as x approaches
really large values really positive
values f of x is going to be approaching
that value that asymptote from above and
as x becomes really negative it looks
like f of x is approaching that from
below but how would we be able to figure
that out just by looking at this
well one thought experiment is just to
say well what happens to f of x as x
approaches infinity so let me write that
down
as x
approaches infinity
then
then f of x is going to approach what
well as x approaches larger and larger
values the positive 10 and the negative
15 start to matter a lot less that the
highest degree term in the numerator and
denominator start to dominate
so we could say as x approaches infinity
f of x
is getting closer and closer to 2x
over 5x which is
which is two-fifths which is equal to
two-fifths so you could say f of x is
approaching two-fifths and if you really
wanna kind of see that a little bit more
a little bit more concretely
let's imagine different values for x as
x gets larger and larger and larger so
if we have
so x
f of x if x is 1 then f of x is just
going to be 2 plus 10
over 5 minus 15. so here the 10 and the
negative and the subtracting the 15
matter a lot
but if x was if x were a thousand then f
of x would be 2 000
plus 10
over 5 000
minus 15. so now the 2000 and 5000 are
really kind of setting the agenda and
then if x were if x were let's say 1
million
1 million
and i just used blue for more contrast
then f of x would be 2 million 2 million
plus 10. let me move over to the right a
little bit 2 million plus 10
over
5 million
5 million minus 15. so here the 10 and
the 15 are almost inconsequential and
you can imagine if x were a billion or
trillion or google then these then the
10 and the negative 15 starting to
matter a lot a lot less so as x
approaches infinity these matter less
the higher degree terms the highest
degree terms matter so f of x is going
to approach 2x over 5x which is
two-fifths so f of x is approaching
two-fifths and that's what this line
looks like two-fifths is the same thing
as point four
so f of x and we see that in the graph f
x is approaching that but it's not quite
getting close to it it's not quite
getting there it's getting closer and
closer to it as x goes to infinity but
it's not quite getting there because
you're always going to have that plus 10
and that minus 15 there so you're never
going to be exactly at two-fifths
and the same thing is happening as x
gets more and more and more negative you
can make all of these negative values so
if if this were negative 1 that would be
negative 2 negative 5 this was negative
a thousand would be negative two
thousand over negative five thousand if
there were negative a million it would
be negative two million over negative
five million but you see even in this
case f of x is approaching two x over
five x which is approaching two-fifths
or you can see it's approaching negative
two over negative five which is still
two-fifths and you see that right over
here
so we would say that this function has a
horizontal asymptote
horizontal
horizontal
asymptote
asymptote
at
y equals the horizontal line right over
here is y
is equal to two-fifths
so hopefully this graph here is helping
us appreciate what these vertical and
horizontal asymptotes actually are but
if we didn't have the graph we could
have said okay we're undefined at x
equals three we could test some values
around it and so we could say okay look
it does look like we're approaching
negative infinity as x approaches
negative 3 from the left it looks like
we're approaching positive at infinity
as x approaches negative 3 from the
right so we could we could put we could
draw that kind of blue point right there
we could graph these two points when
does f equal 0 what happens to f when x
equals 0 and then we could think about
the behavior as x approaches infinity or
negative infinity as x approaches
negative as x approaches infinity or
negative infinity and draw this
horizontal asymptote and between all of
those that would have been a pretty good
way to be able to sketch this actual
graph